pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
it's Friday
I see nothing but fog clouds and danger
pilot to Bombardier
pilot the bumper dear please come in
oh [ __ ] it's debt on two legs for you
[ __ ] maybe putting an ant in here
to kill the [ __ ] flavor
[Laughter]
just like that motherfucker's Friday
July 15th three months away from my
[ __ ] special and Rose month training
is on [ __ ] and it all starts right
now with the reef of debt I hope you're
having a great thing I hope your worlds
beautiful my nose is still [ __ ] up but
it's getting better the smell of fart
again and that's all it matters but
enough footage in the channel for Joey
let's look at the [ __ ] herb man free
it's fried let's finish up there's King
Louie the [ __ ] 19th but tremendous
blend and it'll get you nice and [ __ ]
stoned what's up you bad ball the [ __ ]
is you but I forgot about you kind of
suck he'll know how much uncle Joey
loves you [ __ ] do you got your
paycheck it's kind of [ __ ] pay the
piper with your uncle Joey
enough with the chitty-chat
people through the tulips you bet
[ __ ] uncle Joey here burning it
down
got a [ __ ] solo tipped on that
collection no but week is over you guys
[ __ ] did your gold you went to work
you got your dick sucked
now it's Friday Saturday is something
we're gonna do in life the star there's
uncle Joey tapping in with you mother
[ __ ]
I still can't work out the stitches you
know the [ __ ] deal but I'll be
walking in this heat sweat with those
oxys
well that's it no edibles this week but
I just been Lauren are in it writing
notes of the thoughts that come into my
mind you understand me when a Joey
we don't know [ __ ] thoughts we want
to get high [ __ ] enough is enough
let's do this [ __ ] let me just clean
this poll out here I got some Louise I
picked up this morning [ __ ] tremendous
oh I picked this [ __ ] after
10:30 and I left it in my car I opened I
took the thing back
I lost the [ __ ] lack of Sun coming
through the sunroof and burning this
week down to the port all that's left is
THC understand me why why because I'm
like no we tried
well here we go look at this
this is
xxx oh [ __ ] from Sunset arable the home
of local Joey's stars of [ __ ] death
you understand this has to have a blood
coming out of my nose I give it a couple
of bumps and went out too fast I'm
saying but [ __ ] let's smoke this [ __ ]
and we'll see how this is it's Friday
and you can't walk on one leg
this nation we take this moment to smile
you don't say
nice nice we get together just Mowgli
this is him they'll talk didn't know
[ __ ] bullshitting just us like a
family smoking reefer you never thought
your wildest [ __ ] dreams could I be
dead at a certain time you uncle joy
pops up boom and then your get now like
[ __ ] Bob Marley and we smoke
[ __ ] we get stoned to the gills
when I can finish you in your living
room hearing voices like Robin Williams
what who did
nice same time people where do you get
this what was [ __ ] continent do you
get together with your favorite [ __ ]
uncle every day for about you know six
minutes and just smokin um and talk
about life any plans you know we don't
even give the media show just a [ __ ]
about what the [ __ ] about you
[ __ ] you know why did you give
a [ __ ] about me right here it don't get
no better than this you think about what
the [ __ ] I'm telling you this will be
created no no nobody [ __ ] told this
nobody wrote a book about this [ __ ]
get together with a bunch of cool buzz
and smokin no drop in genies right just
us come on you meant the feds gonna pop
in on the cops who gives a [ __ ]
Letterman we ain't shootin like people
here we're doing the right [ __ ] thing
oh yeah
oh yeah this is just getting ready for
the afternoon
my wife is gonna yoga for got the house
to myself
I was watching [ __ ] duck now let's
drop everything I'm [ __ ] 3439 ESPN
you don't beat though I'll give you the
best [ __ ] to watch nice listen doc
Goodman [ __ ] Daryl strawberry top him
down last name with dirty 4:30 is out
right now if you got ESPN and relax that
pick the baby up about a quarter to 6
ain't going dick tonight that's it
that's my [ __ ] weekend just
recuperate to get the nose intact so I
could smell my love once I get out there
and rip up [ __ ] clubs you understand
me the way we're supposed to [ __ ] we
want you to come for my [ __ ] jokes
I'm going on more festival West Palm
Beach [ __ ] Sebastian Tommy Sakura
uncle Joey are you [ __ ] kidding me or
what if you don't shut up with heroin
your flop and slip and [ __ ] stop this
but before that I'll see you at Oklahoma
at the Cherokee Casino Wallace 6 then
the final we can smoke and dope which
you find savages in Denver we're gonna
rewrite the Constitution when I get
there
Joey you give me a big pony don't like
dates I just want to get stole my Uncle
Joe I got [ __ ] that no people to see
which remind the Fishman to let up
[ __ ] Pole
I didn't think something that's it we're
just getting the weekend went well
people ask you where you come from I was
an uncle [ __ ] enjoyment then but cannot
be words don't [ __ ] around those tickets
are gonna cry don't little stories a
model that shows whatever sells it's
over that's it
I don't never [ __ ] a - oh [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that's what it's time for with
Uncle Joe
am I gonna even edible tonight and I'm
giving it some time
couple of weeks I've talked to the stars
at that man today we're gonna hook up
next week and mr. [ __ ] walking again
tomorrow I walk today I walk yesterday
will sweat sweat those things I can't do
no to Jitsu look how big this [ __ ]
target is you missed em you get me with
a [ __ ] toehold and also to open some
alyssum wakes with missable impetus look
at some Sun stick the mammal diet no
money pilot to Bombardier violate the do
that's it that's it I don't know Joe you
know how we do it
this is true as amazing as again this is
funky
a fraction
is this way would've - we do smoke dope
look at each other for thumb in three
minutes
getting handsomer by the day and that's
it I gotta go I'm gonna take two steps
to the rear and get out of here listen
to me I Love You God suckers have a
great weekend be safe keep you guys hope
in case the Taliban wants to make a
guest appearance at the restaurant
you're insane sit next to the back door
she could run straight if that based on
slant and a [ __ ] to live drizzle so on
the way the restaurant tower listen once
I hear a bully strike grab you by the
throat my dragon you leave everything to
heal I don't give a [ __ ] thank you for
giving me a [ __ ] life nothing
nothing you guys gave me a life right so
every day he did something good if you
party with Uncle Joe
we'll see each other maybe maybe later
you know me the real deal is boy if a
gentleman mother Bobby Nyland throw